you look really good oh thanks you look
very uh i don't know you look very zen
you look you look very good you look
thing
are you are you because i think a lot of
us
i'll speak for myself but you've been on
my show
they they paint a ton of makeup on me oh
my god
i appear on camera i'm really enjoying
like i'm not just saying this
like that celebrity i'm not wearing
makeup i'm honestly not wearing anything
right
now because it's a zoom and i just
thought it started to think
the first couple zoom interviews i did i
was trying to put makeup on and i
thought what am i doing who cares
and this i don't know i'm kind of really
liking not wearing makeup are you
liking that i love it so much i'm i was
gonna ask you about it like who's doing
your makeup now because it's something
i i just it's you don't go on tv without
makeup i mean it's unheard of
it's um but i love that we're getting
back to it i feel like a lot like
the planet is he healing women's faces
are like
getting back to their natural state like
a lot like the
the venice canals dolphins are swimming
in them now it's like women have
lines on their face i really i want to
get in here and show you some stuff that
i got going
i my botox is completely gone like it's
still going right here
but i got back this was so smooth before
and now it's like a washboard i've been
washing my intimates
in the sink on it which is really
helpful since the laundry mats are
closed
um and i also my eyebrows
are i don't know if you can see this but
they're really long i look like abe
vegota
i'm having they're so so long and it
just feels good
to look like um just to be in my natural
seat again and the thing is though
i do have i did my own makeup today i
really do have a lot on
when i wash my face later it's just
gonna run brown
like looks like i'm living in flint
michigan it's
the it's it's ridiculous how much paint
goes into looking good
and i haven't been wearing makeup just
in my daily life
and it's it's been great for my skin
because it is weird women are expected
it's great that we can cover up
zits like it's nice to be a woman and
like when a guy as is it you just have
to have a zit
and we can stuff an open wound with like
dirt clay and wonder why it keeps coming
back
over and over yeah so it is nice to get
back tomorrow but i just
the other day i was um i was i haven't
been wearing makeup my dad really thinks
like
because without makeup i look different
my dad thinks he his long-lost son
returned home he keeps asking me to
play catch and
[Laughter]
build a deck i'm just like dad i'm a
girl but the other day i did put on
makeup because i had like a zoom call
with
some guy who's rejected me in the past
and um so i put on a little
contour and some mascara and i swear i
went to the kitchen
and my dad kind of did a double take and
was like you look beautiful and i was
just like
see dad it's it's true like you like me
better with makeup like
it's all is it it's what's in the inside
that counts and he's like can you
drink some makeup then because you're
not
nice so i just chugged some
covergirl and uh yeah that's good that's
you don't need to serve my corona
yeah if you drink makeup you do not need